so this morning Jonathan major spoke
with Good Morning America and he spoke
up for the very first time not only
since he was found guilty of assaulting
his ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari but also
really for the first time since he was
arrested him and his law team since he
was arrested have stated over and over
again that he was innocent and that he
was actually the victim in the situation
that happened Jonathan Majors was
arrested in March of 2023 then he was
charged with four cases of assault
against his ex-girl Grace Jabari then in
December he was found guilty of Reckless
assault in the third degree and guilty
of harassment now in an exclusive
interview on Good Morning America which
is actually owned by Disney and we'll
get into that story in just a bit he has
opened up about the entire trial the
entire situation and is asked yet again
if he did assault his ex-girlfriend and
which he continuously denies so let's
Dive Right into this interview and break
it down keep in mind we can only show
some clips due to copyright reasons but
we'll link the whole interiew interview
in the pin comment down below and they
did state that there is an extended
version of this interview coming out
tonight at 700 p.m. if there is a lot
more information than that we'll do a
breakdown of that as well and these are
two separate videos that Good Morning
America released this morning consisting
of the same interview they just broke
him down into two different parts and
we'll cover both in this video in this
interview Jonathan major states that he
did not physically abuse his
ex-girlfriend that he is going to appeal
the Court's decision in hopes that it
could be turned around around and he
could be found not guilty and he states
that he does not think that his
Hollywood career as an actor is over the
interview is conducted by Lindsey Davis
and she starts off by stating that
Jonathan major is adamant that there was
absolutely no physical abuse in the
relationship with him and his
ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari he calls the
two-year relationship with Grace Jabari
toxic dangerous and unhealthy but he is
animate he says there was absolutely no
physical abuse they then state that he
could still face up to a year in prison
and the interviewer asks why now why
speak up now which Jonathan major said
this why did you decide you wanted to
talk now I felt like it was
time
um a lot has
happened um in my personal life in my
career um in the culture it's about
responsibility and coming forward and
being brave and and giving my my my part
of the story she then asked about his
reaction to the verdict in which he said
he was absolutely shocked story your
reaction to that
verdict
shock I was uh I was absolutely shocked
and
um afraid I'm standing there and the
verdict comes down I say how how how is
how is that possible
based off the evidence based off the
prosecution's
evidence let alone our evidence how was
that possible Good Morning America then
goes over the events that really took
place the night before he was arrested
stating that he got a text from another
woman that said oh how I wish to be
kissing you in which his girlfriend at
the time Grace Jabari grabbed his phone
where she claimed he physically tried to
get it back from her fracturing her
finger and hurting her behind the right
ear the interviewer says she said says
that you did all of these things to her
to physically abuse her and Jonathan
major straight up says that never
happened she says inside the car you hit
her in the face twist her arm behind her
back fracture her middle finger yeah
that did not happen how did those
injuries come
about I I wish to God I
knew that would give Clarity that would
give me some type of Peace about
it but you're confident you didn't I
have no question then after this Majors
puts focus on him running away from
Grace Jabari in which they do show the
footage of him getting out of the car
running away and she follows him and he
makes a really good point stating that
if the roles were reversed it would have
been very different what happens next is
what the defense remains focused on
Majors runs off and Jabari chases after
him if you watch those
videos and you reverse that and you saw
a black man chasing a young white girl
down the street screaming and crying
that man is going to be shot and killed
in the streets of New York City they
then show that Jonathan major actually
had injuries himself from Grace Jabari
how were you injured my injuries were um
had a scratch on my hand you know from
clawing for the phone and I had a gash
on my at the time I had a beard under my
beard I had essentially a singing out
scratch on my guess my cheek from
pressure and and that bled over they
then go on to talk about how the
prosecution stated Jonathan major to be
an abuser both physical and emotional
and mental as well bringing up previous
times in the relationship where Jonathan
major showed these signs including a
time where he got mad and he threw a
candle on the ground in which Jonathan
major said yes I did do that he said I
completely lost my temper in the moment
and threw it all on the ground he said I
absolutely did that it's not something
that I would want my child to do and I
feel absolutely terrible about it they
also then talk about the audio that was
recorded by Grace Jabari of Jonathan
major speaking to her telling her that
she needed to be like ketta Scott King
and Michelle Obama in which Jonathan
major finally addressed what this was
all about here's what he said it was me
trying
to give an analogy of of what it is I'm
aspiring to be you know these Great
Men
Martin President Obama um trying to give
a reference point to that one of the
things I also say is
like I need her in that that case Grace
to make the same sacrifices that I am
making and then in the final question of
the first clip Lindsay asked him do you
feel that you are not responsible for
any of Grace jabari's injuries at all
and his response is very interesting
because in his response he does admit
that he stepped out on the relationship
he was seeing another woman and if he
had the courage to end his relationship
with Grace Jabari then he wouldn't have
been the situation at all do you feel
you're not responsible for her injuries
at all I shouldn't have been in the
car I shouldn't have stepped out of the
relationship I shouldn't have been in
the relationship if I'm not in the
car none of this is
happening if I leave the relationship
none of this is
happening if I'm man enough or brave
enough to
say I want to see somebody else
or I'm I'm done
now I'm not in that
car we're not here I'm responsible for
those things but none of her injuries I
can't say that none of her injuries then
Lindsay states that his sentencing is
less than a month away but legal
analysts state that he is very unlikely
to spend any time in jail at all and she
makes it clear that Jonathan major has
said that he is planning to appeal so to
Jonathan major this is not over yet he
is going to appeal the Court's decision
then Lindsay states that Jonathan major
never took the stand during the trial we
all wondered why he never testified in
which Lindsay then stated major said he
always planned to take the stand and
testify but didn't in the end because he
felt that the prior testimony was so
compelling that he felt that there was
nothing else that he could add but now
that the jury has spoken he felt that it
was time to tell his side of the story
then the interview begins and Good
Morning America does a good job job at
painting the entire picture here they
show Jonathan major stating how hard his
life was a clip that we showed in the
beginning of this video and then they
dive into what happened being sure to
state that he was actually found not
guilty to two of the charges against him
they state in a split verdict he was
found not guilty of two other
misdemeanors assault with intent to
cause physical injury and aggravated
assault in which they do a great job of
explaining the difference between the
charges he was found not guilty of and
guilty of very clearly expressing that
the charges he was found guilty of was
harassment that was unintentional so
they asked did this really happen did he
assault her even though it was
unintentional did it happen here's what
he said in a split verdict Majors was
found not guilty of two other
misdemeanor assault with intent to cause
physical injury and aggravated assault
they're saying you didn't intend to
injure her right but the result of your
recklessness injured her right were you
Reckless
I was Reckless with her
heart not with her body not with her
body so again Majors denies ever hurting
her ever abusing her harassing her or
causing any physical pain to her at all
intentional or unintentional or
recklessly he only says that he was
Reckless with her heart because he
stepped out on the relationship they
then go on to state that Jonathan major
was the one who actually called the
police after the altercation took place
and Jonathan major ran away from her and
they separated that night he went back
to his apartment and found her
unconscious on the floor and he's the
one who called the police and the
interviewer asked if he felt that he did
anything wrong that night and if he
could relive it if he would do anything
differently in which he said this you
feel that you did anything wrong on the
night of March 25th if you could relive
that night I wouldn't have picked her
up I wouldn't have picked her up I
wouldn't have put her back in the car I
wouldn't have tried to keep her in the
car I would have gotten out that car and
ran immediately the interviewer then
says that the prosecution described his
relationship with Grace Jabari as
abusive in which Jonathan Maes replied
no I loved Grace and the relationship
was toxic and it was a term that he used
Dangerous and he should have had the
courage to end the relationship but he
was scared and he says that he should
have been brave and he should have told
her this isn't working and he should
have walked away but he didn't she also
asked him about the text where he
threatened suicide in which he stated
that he's worked through that he's not
there anymore he's not in that place
where he would want to remove himself
from a situation in such an extreme case
and he said that he's worked through
that he's not there anymore that's not
the place mentally where he is at then
they asked a big question when Jonathan
major was arrested a lot of people came
out talking about how abusive Jonathan
major actually was mentally and
physically and they've stated that some
of his past partners have basically
painted the picture that he is indeed in
one way or another an abusive boyfriend
an abusive partner but Lindsay
specifically asks have you ever
physically abused any of your past
partners and this is what he said I've
had very few relationships um so I can I
can I can gather um what situations
we're talking about um yeah I was not
the best boyfriend all the time but
never hit a woman never hit a woman I've
never my hands have never struck a woman
ever then in the final part of this
interview they go on to state that
before this all happened Majors was in
his prime but moments after he was found
guilty Marvel Studios dropped him as
king the Conqueror so they ask do you
think your career in Hollywood is done
you think you'll ever work in Hollywood
again yeah yeah I do I pray I do but
it's uh it's God's plan and God's timing
and then the final question is do you
think you deserve a second chance and he
States this what would you say I mean do
you deserve a second
chance I think I
do I hope other people think that
now this is where we get into more of
the pr side of this interview like I
mentioned this was conducted by Good
Morning America which is on ABC News
which Disney owns which means Marvel
Studios and Disney fire Jonathan Majors
but then let him go on ABC news for the
first exclusive interview of him
speaking out talking about how he
believes he is still innocent and I do
think this was a great interview I think
it shed a lot of light on the situation
especially as to how Jonathan major
particularly feels and also let us know
that he is going to appeal and he hopes
that he gets a second chance so now
people are really asking well is this
just kind of a move by Disney to get the
public kind of on his side to hear his
side of the story to where if they do
rehire him as king the Conqueror for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe then they
won't really get a lot of flak for it
this is basically a way for them to kind
of gauge The public's interest to see
what people would think if they rehired
him and this absolutely very well could
be the case and I think a lot of people
actually hope hope that this is the case
a lot of people think that this was an
unjust ruling that they did not have
enough evidence to prove that Jonathan
major was abusive to her at all or that
he caused her injuries especially when
Jonathan major had injuries of his own
and was running away from Grace Jabari
trying to get away from her this
interview was very well done to show the
side of Jonathan Majors to show how he
saw everything and how he said
everything happened and he admitted to
the parts where he was wrong he said
that he did cheat on her he said that he
stepped out he said that he should have
broken up with her he should have ended
the relationship he shouldn't have tried
to put her back inside the car but
remained adamant that he never
physically abused her he never hurt her
or any of his past girlfriends and even
his current girlfriend Megan Good was
present in the interview and they did
show her for a brief moment in time but
this was absolutely very strategic by
Jonathan Major's part during the trial a
lot went out against him without his
side really being presented and now he
has presented his side and hopes that
people will hear him that they'll
believe him and give him a second chance
so let us know what you think about all
of this down below do you think he
deserves a second chance do you think he
could win his appeal and do you think he
might return as king the Conqueror in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe let us
know your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and if you subscribe and leave
a comment you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for chance one A PS5 and
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter if you'd like
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof